[Music]
the single biggest race I guess to the
thieves and always gonna be the Tour de
France and then we've done pretty well
Rita dear so we'd like to go back and
perform well there it's the one event
that all time fish to the customers say
the holy grail of cycling if you like
the frenzy around the race just the fans
the color the noise I mean it's it it's
special you just feel the passion from
Edward and you get so close you can
smell a good beer on people's breath and
yeah it's just a massive buzz and
through them your real through the tours
fantastic when you're there it's it's
intense there's so many people it is
different different world really yes so
one of the first things that we do is we
sit down we get all the roots of all the
Grand Tours out and we start to what we
call analyze our demands of the events
every tour is different year hog year
but or changes its profile it changes
with speeds intensities and deviations
and so forth and we start to get a real
feel for the sort of characteristic to
that particular race and so then we we
kind of go from demands early event down
into another layer where the task figure
out what it takes to win you know I
think it got you with the physical side
the mental side in equipment side
aerodynamics and nutrition when we say
nutrition we're really talking about
fuelling recovery of immune and health
and getting to the right body
composition
contrary to popular belief some of the
stage engine observe maybe are not as
hard as what people would think
so perhaps on a mountain speeds their
recovery at will expert nutrition you
know hitting those real high
carbohydrate intake is high protein
increase but perhaps on a flux PhD in
10:30 disappeared seven commanders at
amount of nutrition so then you can kind
of reduce the amount of fuel that we use
to recover and over the course of that
24-hour period for your total energy
intake is lower compared to their minds
and speeds and over the course of the
three weeks day by day
skiers biospheres nutrition ensures that
we try and stay right at that peak level
of body composition that we need to fuel
winning performances nutrition is a
massive part now especially on the road
there's more times we go after more
taking nutrition in new ways and the
diet and everything's effectuated and
throughout Grand Tour you can do well
over 30 hours of you know you need to be
able to be optimum level but obviously
not putting weight on or losing weight
so it's a fine balance and something
that certainly working wrong more after
the yoga by believe the 2016 Tour de
France was quite interesting actually to
that first nine days was a real big
block loss so we have to make sure that
we fueled really well you have to manage
people's body composition the keeper's
fresh for week two and week three and I
think that close attention to the first
nine days and 2016 really made sure that
we were fresh for the second and more
importantly for the third week and
that's when we really shoulders are to
strengthen numbers
[Music]
the Tour de France in 2017 is going to
be a really tough challenge for me given
the run many summit finishes it's very
very low in time trial kilometers as
well so there aren't many opportunities
to really make a difference in the race
but there are three summit finishes and
from my point of view effort we're
really trying to make those three some
finishes come you know Chris's developed
really well and I think not just his
physical side but just also the mental
side the biggest thing I've learned is
the way in which he takes people with
him and the way talks to his teammates
that's one of the key elements for being
a tall leader taking the team with you
it's a big psychological battle you know
it really is and I think that's what
give quizzes crispy ads in read to
situation never gives up we've instinct
is to go for that line and I think it
separates it from the rest room I never
never drank in my wildest dreams that
that I would have won two or three times
it's just such an amazing experience you
go through such a journey with your
teammates and that support team around
you all the build-up to the tour and all
the all the hurdles along the way and
it's a massive challenge and to win a
race like that it just it's such a
special feeling so it's it's hard not to
be motivated to to want to go back there
and do it again